welcome everyone this is part four in
our series on natural language inference
we're going to be talking about
different modeling strategies you might
think of this screencast as a companion
to the associated notebook that explores
a lot of different modeling ideas and
suggests some architectural variations
that you might explore yourself
i thought we would start by just
considering hand-built feature functions
because they can still be quite powerful
for the nli problem
so some standard hand built feature
ideas include as a kind of baseline word
overlap between the premise and
hypothesis this is giving you a kind of
pretty small feature space
essentially measuring how the premise
and hypothesis are alike
if you want to step it up a level you
could consider the word cross product
features which you just consider as its
feature space
every pairing of a word in the premise
and a word in the hypothesis this will
give you a massive feature space very
large very sparse but the intuition
behind it might be that you're allowing
your model a chance to discover
points of alignment and disalignment
between the premise and the hypothesis
and so that could be very powerful
you might also consider additional word
net relations bringing those in
these would be things like entailment
and contradiction and autonomy synonymy
and those of course could be nicely
keyed into the underlying logic of the
nli problem
edit distance is another common feature
but just a raw float value between
premise and hypothesis as a kind of high
level way of comparing those two texts
word differences might be a nice
juxtaposition with word overlap you
could be considering ways in which the
premise and hypothesis contrast with
each other in that feature space
and we can also move to alignment based
features i mentioned that word cross
product is kind of an attempt to have
the model learn points of alignment
between the premise and hypothesis but
of course we could also do some things
kind of even before we begin to learn
feature weights trying to figure out
which pieces in the premise correspond
to which piece is in the hypothesis
we could consider negation we've seen of
course that that's an important
indicator function in a lot of nli data
sets there's a powerful intuition behind
that especially as it pertains to
contradiction and so maybe we would
write some feature functions that were
explicitly keyed into the presence or
absence of negation in various spots in
the premise and hypothesis
and we could also step that up a level
as well and consider more generally all
kinds of different interesting
quantifier relationships that would hold
possibly at the level of an alignment as
in item six here between the premise and
hypothesis and this is kind of keying
into the underlying logic of the nli
problem
and then finally named entity
recognition we've seen that these
features might be important in figuring
out which entities co-refer across the
premise and hypothesis and so having
some devices for figuring that out could
be useful uh for as a kind of low-level
grounding for your system
now let's move into a mode that's more
like the deep learning mode because as
we saw uh earlier in the screencast
series these models have proven at this
point to be the most powerful models for
the nli problems so it's productive to
think also about different deep learning
architectures and i'd like to start with
what i've called here sentence and
coding models the most basic form of
that would return to idea of distributed
representations as features
so the idea here is that we have in this
diagram the premise and the hypothesis
so the premises every dog danced and the
hypothesis is every poodle moved
and our approach using distributed
representations the simplest one would
be that we're going to simply look up
all of those words in some fixed
embedding space which would be like a
glove embedding space for example
and then we're going to separately
encode the premise and hypothesis by for
example doing the sum or average
of the vectors in each of those two
texts so that gives us a vector xp and
xh
and then we might concatenate those two
or do something some other kind of
comparison like difference or max or
mean
uh to get a single fixed dimensional
representation x that is then the input
to a kind of could be a simple softmax
classifier
so all we've done here is take our old
approach using distributed
representations as features and move it
into the nli problem where we have both
the premise and hypothesis
and i've called this a sentence encoding
model because we are separately encoding
the two sentences and then the model is
going to learn we hope something about
how those two representations interact
on this slide and the next i've given a
complete recipe for doing exactly what i
just described i'm not going to linger
over here because it's also in the
notebooks and it just shows you how
using our course code it can be
relatively easy to set up models like
this most of the code is devoted to
doing the low level processing of the
words into their embedding space
here's the rationale for sentencing
coding models i think this is kind of
interesting right we might want to
encode the premise and hypothesis
separately in order to give the model a
chance to find rich abstract
relationships between them
the sentence encoding approach might
also facilitate transfer to other kinds
of tasks right to the extent that we are
separately encoding the two sentences we
might have sentence level
representations that are useful even for
problems that don't fit into the
specific nli mode of having a single
premise and a single hypothesis for the
sake of classification and that could be
an important part of that vision from
dagen at all that nli is a kind of
source of effective pre-training for
more general problems
let's move to a more complex model we'll
follow the same narrative that we've
used before we just had that simple
fixed model that was going to combine
the premise and hypothesis via some
fixed function like sum or average or
max
here we're going to have functions that
learn about how those interactions
should happen but we're going to follow
the sentence in coding mode so i have
our same example every dog danced and
every poodle moved and the idea is that
each one of those is processed by its
own separate recurrent neural network
and i've indicated in green that
although these two models would have the
same structure these are different
parameters for the premise and
hypothesis so they function separately
and then in the simplest approach we
would take the final hidden
representation from each of those and
combine them somehow probably via
concatenation and that would be the
input to the final classifier layer or
layers that actually learn the nli
problem
so it's a sentence encoding approach in
the sense that h3 and hd are taken to be
kind of separate summary representations
of the premise and hypothesis
respectively and we have a vision that
those representations might be
independently useful even outside of the
nli context
now in the associated notebook nli
2 models
there are a bunch of different
implementations including a full pi
torch implementation using our
pi torch based classes of the sentence
encoding rnn approach that i just
described to you and i thought it would
just briefly give you a high level
overview of how that modeling approach
works
because they're actually just a few
moving pieces and the rest is kind of
low level implementation details
so the first thing that you need to do
is modify the data set class
so that conceptually it is going to
create lists of pairs of examples with
their lengths and their associated
labels by default the underlying code
that we're using expects one sequence of
tokens one length and one label and here
we just need to raise that up so that we
have two as you can see here every dog
danced every poodle moved both happen to
have link three and their label is
entailment so we make some changes to
the dataset class to accommodate that
change in format essentially
then the core model for this is
conceptually just two rnns and the
forward method is just essentially
bringing those two pieces together and
feeding them to the subsequent
classifier layers and so that's very
conceptually natural and it's just down
to having two separate rnns that you
implement
using the raw materials that are already
there in the code
and then finally for the actual
interface the torch rnn sentence encoder
classifier this is basically unchanged
with the one modification that you need
to change the predict problem method the
fundamental method for prediction
because it too needs to deal with this
different data set format that we
established up here and that is again a
kind of low level change and so what i
hope you're seeing is that the first and
third steps are kind of managing the
data
and the middle step is the one that
actually modifies the computation graph
but that step is very intuitive because
we're basically just reflecting in code
our idea that we have separate rnns for
the premise and hypothesis
and then finally i just want to mention
that a common approach you see
especially in the early literature is a
sentence encoding tree nnn that has
exactly the same intuition behind it as
the rnns that we just looked at except
that the premise and hypothesis are
processed by tree structured recur uh
recursive neural networks and since the
underlying data sets often have full
parse representations this is an avenue
that you could explore
it can be tricky to implement these
efficiently but conceptually it's a kind
of very natural thing where you just
repeatedly have a dense layer at every
one of the constituent nodes on up to a
final representation here pb and pd that
is then fed into the classifier layer in
just the way we've done for the previous
models
so those are the sentence encoding rnns
now let's move to a different vision and
i've called these chained models because
they're going to just
mush together the premise and hypothesis
as opposed to separately encoding the
two
of course the simplest thing we could do
in the chain mode would be to
essentially ignore the fact that we have
two texts the premise and hypothesis and
just feed them in as one long sequence
into a standard recurrent neural network
and since that involves no changes to
any of the code we've been using for rnn
classifiers it seems like a pretty
natural baseline and so that's depicted
here
and actually this can be surprisingly
effective
right the rationale for doing this
in this context here you could say that
the premise
is simply establishing context for
processing the hypothesis and that seems
like a very natural notion of
conditioning on one text as you process
the second one and correspondingly at
the level of human language processing
this might actually correspond to
something that we do
as we read through our premise
hypothesis text and figure out what the
relationship is
and here's a simple recipe for doing
this the one change from the diagram
that you might think about is that i did
when representing the examples here
flatten them out of course
but also insert this boundary marker
that would at least give the model a
chance to learn that there was a
separation happening some kind of
transition between the premise and
hypothesis
but that's just the level of
featurization and in terms of modeling
you hardly need to make any changes in
order to run this kind of experiment
we could also think about a modification
that would bring together sentence
encoding with chained and this would be
where we have two sets of rnn parameters
one for the premise and one for the
hypothesis but we nonetheless chain them
together instead of separately encoding
them so as before i have a premise rnn
in green
i have a hypothesis rnn and purple they
have the same structure but different
learned parameters and the handoff is
essentially that the initial hidden
state for the hypothesis is the final
output state for the premise and in that
way you get a seamless transition
between these two models
and this would allow the model some
space to learn that premise tokens and
premise sequences have a different
status than those that appear in the
hypothesis
and let me just close by mentioning a
few other strategies because this was by
no means exhaustive but it's kind of
interesting at the high level of
architecture thinking about sentencing
coding versus these chained models
so first the torch rnn classifier feeds
its hidden state directly to the
classifier layer but we have options
like bi-directional equals true which
would use as the summary representation
both the final and the initial hidden
states essentially and feed those into
the classifier so it's a different
notion of sentencing coding or of
sequence encoding
and other ideas here right so we could
instead of restricting just to one or a
few of the final states do some kind of
pooling with max or mean across all of
the output states
and different pooling options can be
combined with different versions of
these models either sentence encoding
or chained we could also of course have
additional hidden layers between the
classifier layer and the embedding i've
shown you just one for the sake of
simplicity but deeper might be better
especially for the very large nli data
sets that we have
and finally an important source of
innovation in this and many other spaces
is the idea of adding attention
mechanisms to these models and that's
such an important idea that i'm going to
save it for the next screencast in this
series